نبقى مشاهدينا في اخبار كاس العالم
والحماس الكبير اللي خلى الناس ترجع 36
سنه وتذكر المشجع الارجنتيني روبرتو سيغاس
الحمل مارادونا على اكتافه في 86 وبيحلم
اليوم انه يحمل ميسي كمان واللي اللي
بيسال مثلا ايش يعني بعد 36 عام وهلت عيد
التاريخ نفسه
بالتحديد في لانه ببساطه هذه الرجل سافر
في 86 من الارجنتين الى المكسيك عشان يحضر
المباراه النهائيه لكاس العالم بين
الارجنتين والمانيا من دون ما تكون معه
تذكره حضور للمباراه يعني انتم متخيلين في
ذلك الوقت
وبس كده كمان قدر انه يحشر كده نفسه ضمن
الحشود ويشيل مارادونا على اكتافه وحامل
كاس العالم وهذا الشيخ اللي لاعب كره
القدم الارجنتيني مارتن الناس وكان نوع
يعني من التفاعل والاحتفال المسبق سلوفرته
سيغسلي لقطر لحضور المباراه النهائيه بس
في اختلاف واحد انه هذه المره معه تذكره
وكمان هذه المره في حلم بيحلم فيه روبرتو
وهو انه كمان يحمل ميسي مثل محمد مارادونا
في 86